frau müller hat die gruppe verlassen
dann schreibt ein anderer lehrer frau
müller steht vor der aufgabe und wie das
fand ich sehr witzig übrigens etwas
glaubt netz willkommen beim ein video ja
leid ich hoffe natürlich euch jetzt gut
ja weil ich habe mich für das heutige
video was ganz besonderes überlegt weil
sind auch die abiturprüfungen und dann
ist ein schuljahr schon wieder rum und
ich bin gerade zu hause weil mehr eltern
und habe meine abiturzeitung gefunden
für die jetzt sich wissen was das genau
ist das ist einfach so ein rückblick von
allen jahren mit fotos sprüchen
steckbriefen über mich also jetzt nicht
nur über mich sondern auch über meine
mitschüler damals und da sind eine menge
witzige sachen drin und ich habe mir
gedacht
darüber könnte man eigentlich meinen
video machen weil sowas habe ich
generell auf youtube noch nie gesehen
und das heutige wiese entsteht in
kooperation und cornelsen also im
cornelsen verlag und zwar wie schon
gesagt bald das abitur und das gilt
jetzt eigentlich für alle generell ist
eigentlich immer alle schüler wenn ihr
sagt okay ich habe in der schule schon
ab und zu mal schwierigkeiten cornelsen
ist nämlich mit der clevere app auf mich
zugekommen das ist eine app die gerade
in der oberstufen phase sprich zehnter
11 12 13 die klasse wirklich
unterstützen kann ich habe mich mit der
app ein bisschen auseinander gesetzt
wird ihr euch gerne einmal kurz
vorstellen weil sie mir meiner meinung
nach wirklich geholfen hätte im abitur
vor allem was das fach mathe angeht so
leute ich statt jetzt hier einfach mal
die clevere lernt schnell und genau das
richtige so und ich würde sagen wir
wählen jetzt einfach mal hier mathematik
aus das ganze geld hat wie schon gesagt
für englisch mathe und französisch das
heißt wenn ihr gehabt umso besser also
ich will mathematik hier sind alle
themen die die fürs mathe abitur braucht
und man kann immer sofort auch kostenlos
den cleveren test machen man kann jetzt
legen was man für eine schwierigkeit
gerne hätte einfach mittel oder experte
ich würde sagen ich passe mich jetzt
erstmal mit mittelrhein mein abitur
liegt schon im jahr zurück und dann geht
man hier auf test starten einen
blechkuchen wird in der länge in sechs
abschnitte geteilt oder in der breite in
vier abschnitte gleich danach werden
fünf stücke wissen welcher anteil des
gesamten kuchens ist noch übrig also wir
hatten insgesamt 6 mal 4 24 stücke daher
sechs mann in der länge und vier mal in
der breite geteilt wird und danach
werden fünf stück gegessen 24.5 sind 19
das heißt wird 1924 und das ist ich kann
es noch okay das weiß natürlich auch
nicht so die schwerste aufgabe rechne im
kopf
verwende eine bionische formel dass wir
jetzt eine sache da bin ich raus aber
das sind halt sachen die so mit der zeit
wenn man das immer so ein bisschen macht
man hat sein handy immer dabei
eigentlich echt gut man kann dann
einfach im nachhinein weitere module
frei schalten wie zum beispiel noch mehr
mathematische aufgaben auch in
speziellen unterkategorien zb funktion
stochastik und so weiter einmal indem
man halt aufgaben richtig bearbeitet
sonst kann man auch noch sachen kaufen
zusätzlich kann man da noch weitere
module frei schaltet man halt einmal zum
beispiel credit selber er spielt immer
wenn ich irgendwas erfolgreich
abgeschlossen hat bekommt die credits
oder ihr kaufen könnt ihr einfach hier
zum beispiel analytische geometrie
punkte und vektoren den shuffle test für
zehn credits freischalten und können
dann halt machen und auch ganz wichtig
wenn ihr euch die app holt dann benutzt
auf jeden fall den aktionscode alex wie
einfach genauso wie mein youtube name
könnte dann eingeben und können dann
damit noch gratis module freischalten
also alex wie toller name übrigens auch
an dieser stelle also leute wann die
hilfen in englisch französisch oder
mathe brauchen könnt ihr euch die app
ist oben in der video beschreibung
verlinkt viel spaß damit und immer schön
lernen das ist wichtig
so deute und jetzt machen wir weiter mit
meinem abitur buch abos amigos
erstsemester dann fährst du das war mein
abitur motto man schaut euch mal das
cover an
wer das gemacht ich so wir hatten das
immer so dass sie halt vorne drin erst
mal die steckbriefe zu allen schülern
drin waren und ich suche jetzt kurz vor
meinen raus leute hier das bin ich da
unten auf dem foto ich vor eineinhalb
jahren da habe ich noch gelacht
jetzt lag ich auch noch eigentlich
meistens und das hier zum beispiel war
ich als kind auf einem bagger und
deswegen halt bei jedem steckbrief darum
das halt mitschüler was über die person
schreibt also freunde die auch in meiner
studie waren haben sachen über mich
geschrieben ich habe sachen über andere
schieben usw
und ich lese jetzt mal vor was bei mir
steht erster punkt blockbuster wünscht
sich alex wie er hieß ja damals noch
blockbuster habe mich dann irgendwann zu
alexium genannt hier auf youtube war
damals auch schon ich glaube als die
abitur gemacht habe hatte ich so 250.000
abonnenten nation teil zum fahren was
keiner braucht aber cool ist ja das war
meine hort oder hobart und ich bin damit
ab und zu mal in die schule gefahren und
jeder hat mich extrem blöd angeguckt
bemerkt weil ich kein in der stufe erst
einen monat später verlässt das haus nie
ohne kopfhörer
ich bin wirklich immer mit kopfhörern
fahrrad gefahren zur schule wolle man
das ja eigentlich gar nicht darf die
unterstufe steht auf ihn ja weil ich
halt damals von youtube videos gemacht
habe glaube ich mal hat auch der
schifffahrt aus dem lipp gepinkelt
ja wir waren mal ski fahren mit der
ganzen schule nehme der oberstufe und
ihr müsst wissen unser letztes halt
stehen geblieben und ich war ganz
alleine eineinhalb stunden steckte ich
halt in diesem lift fan habe ich halt
raus gepinkelt du bist auch youtuber
oder nee ich bin volleyballer ist auch
eine lustige story
früher waren wir immer im freibad haben
volleyball gespielt und da kam ab und zu
dann halt etwas länger und haben gesagt
hey du hast du youtuber und ich habe
dann halt immer gesagt nein ich bin
volleyball sie später in die video
metropole köln
ich wohne jetzt in köln seit einem jahr
schon unglaublich nicht unsympathisch
junge mit den meisten schon früher hatte
ich eigentlich weniger show hat jetzt
aber es waren schon einige als es
wirklich immer sehr cool hier sachen
nachzulesen einfach so als erinnerung
und ihren wir dann ist auch eine seite
mit zu abstimmungen da sind dann halt
fragen wie lehrer liebling wer wird
millionär wer heiratet zuerst wer ist
der größte pumper und so weiter und da
musste halt jeder abstimmen und dann
sind halt
österreich zustande gekommen ich bin bei
welchem spanischem temperament ist die
unterstufe verfallen auf platz zwei mit
6 1 prozent und wer wird millionär auf
platz 3 108 prozent youtube money ich
muss wirklich sagen ich bin jetzt der
festen überzeugung davon dass ich
eigentlich auch platz eins gehöre
nein spaß wenn ich mal gespannt ob
dieser platz drei wirklich realität wird
irgendwann wenn natürlich cool und eine
sache die ich wirklich auch noch extrem
lustig fanden die haben mir so chad
verläufe von den lehrern auf whatsapp
hat nachgespielt und einen wollte ich
mal vorlesen und zwei der eine lehrer
geschrieben habt ihr schon das neue
blockbuster video gesehen dann hat der
andere lehrer geantwortet wenn ich da
heißt doch jetzt alex wie ich bin mit
meinem server gk ja auch schon unter die
youtuber gegangen schreibt die andere
lehrer wieder mit deinen lernvideos
sowie könnten die lobbys bestimmt nicht
auf dich aufmerksam dann steht euch
jetzt den rahmen von der lehrerin nicht
nennen sie jetzt einfach mal vor müller
hat die gruppe verlassen dann schreibt
ein anderer lehrer frau müller steht
voll fdgb und baby ja das fand ich sehr
witzig übrigens ja leute so viel zu
meinem abi buß hier dieses fotos kann
ich euch auch noch mal kurz zeigen ich
weiß nicht ob man es gut erkennen kann
hier das bin ich zusammen mit lennart
schöne grüße an dieser stelle auch für
die schule da waren wir so eine achte
klasse sieht man dadurch ist eine coole
erinnerung das was mit dem video waren
sich gefallen lassen doch nach oben da
sollt euch die app und ich würde sagen
wir sehen uns morgen oder übermorgen wir
heute schönen tag hat rein